So far, we've been looking at
intersections of two lines in 2D.
But what happens if we
introduce a third line?
Let's look at the system
of equations Ax + By = k1,
Cx + Dy = k2, and Ex + Fy = k3.
Now in general,
unless AB and CD happen to
be parallel vectors, the first two lines
will have a single intersection point.
Similarly, unless AB and
EF are parallel, the first and
third lines will have
a single intersection point.
And likewise the second and third
lines will have a single intersection
unless CD and EF are parallel.
However, there's no guarantee that these
intersection points will all coincide.
Sometimes they can as in this set
of lines that all pass through
a common point.
More generally, as in the set of lines,
the three intersection
points are all distinct.
Since systems of linear equations are
questions about common intersections,
that is points that are common to
all the objects being considered,
this latter case would have
an empty common intersection.
To describe systems with new
common point of intersection,
we use the term inconsistent.
We will be using this
terminology in the future.
So, I wanted to go ahead and
introduce it here.